focusrite of God nightmare mode is just
like it's killing me yeah I don't know
how familiar you are with US presidents
Danny why but I'm putting 10 is that a
bench on this game is that a Lincoln I'm
gonna start thinking part the tower he
never told a lie I'm gonna win about
yeah and I do different map I've mixed
up all the Presidents he'll never know
line them off make me for one giant
president The Lincoln Lawyer enjoy that
wasn't Matthew McConaughey president he
was he was to Lincoln Lawyer like this
all right all right okay other OOP I
think I might have done something you
did your dog is done alright man alright
good change I'm going for trailer I like
I do it is he's doing driller there may
be new king oh yeah boy like a he's got
really good somebody put up a shield I
always go for now is a mining camp yeah
pretty cannon tower shield and then
sometimes it's like go for it trailer
and it's awesome alright so i deftly I
look like a multi-digit driller the
laser might be a little tough cuz
there's that big column you just
wandering right in the middle let's
[ __ ] do the demolisher that's a good
one and so well I'm they're starting
attention at the bomb wats frost breeze
feels pointless I'm familiar with it
it's kind of really no reason I want to
be good and I not use the balloons you
can change the balloon one as well I
gotta go four to five months no no no
what am i doing what everyone okay I go
back throw them worry about mine let's
look at all our office what there's so
much preparation going into the dreamer
just like eh other gun ominous
accelerator
american currency that's technically
illegal it's worth so much right now
wanna get home and get me coppers are
you an aggressive player that are clear
I'm aggressive accelerators gonna be
more expensive it but go for it okay I
like you yeah I didn't jump on it when
he died after all cool calm down okay
okay our kiss let's do it one daughter
oh yeah well perhaps two on 99 cents
after tax here you go king of me I just
people a lot of it fighting against
kings you dead expand to the top right
okay yeah it's great i can hear him
giving her advice well it won't save you
man honey I'm how do you rate than the
bottom yeah you can get the bottom line
as well I'm erima heavier come on oh god
damn it god damn it my CPM look at him
then put a frost I know it start doing
the UM bomb pots right away ok ok just a
little pressure on her organs ain't
gonna be super effectively you can see
if she's gonna do great that's cuter
hello don't you don't you yeah get one
of the great really true and then fire
that and that one is getting the
cooldown bonus from your accelerator oh
yeah 10 okay now boys length or oh look
at the very front for another bill of it
oh really yeah you just really like
really spam those bombs like good as
much I can also put a little pressure on
this almost ago oh great okay all right
I didn't I shot it yo Mary hate going
over there better news you lost our
frustration you know and I'm gonna tease
should I upgrade oh you can't yet well
you missed a mess in the way all right
you second okay oh good you got it right
before it got frost I was oh my gosh
he's going after himself okay put into
the fun brother put another bomb you've
got some 60s you I did it you wanna
having much stuff as you should I not
gotten it that's good we're and that I
aim towards their bills I guess you get
Buster and then your drill is ready to
go you can drill um drop damage okay
yeah exactly cuz if you can get that one
to drop all the way down it
this is wayne Thirsk I'll create some
buddies by boys I'm right burn I
wouldn't ring it from one cannot you go
oh I feel so good Danny upgrade your
phone oh your tears they're so juicy
yeah I want to put a bomb over towards
your headquarters because it'll be out
of range of be here we go fine throw is
gonna in an upgrade I can't go get
another one get rid the shield stop the
flamethrowers no not to I mean the
blocks little welcome Danny I would put
that bomb next to the headquarters
though Danny as far forward as far as
you keep your death is in a bit
animation tomatoes very intimate dad
sign me up but enough frost goddamn it
you're using hacks [ __ ] this all right
okay you wanna get your I would have a
heard county called that before okay
you're right its limbs over again
[ __ ] finger people do one well at
least you got the fortified mine is
gonna be a lot baby daddy all right what
I'll do is your hands out of range now
keep that was firing as often as you can
and you can upgrade the headband and
then keep that uh that one firing yeah
yeah yeah right you got a good Oh
building look another fling says there's
flamethrowers are really low on health
after getting all the bars
man-of-the-match far forward as a can
I'll just be made own trigger a trick
public winter is like yeah invest a lot
in turn thanks coach where they are
that's reassuring it's like you're
pushing haha oh well you know what I'm
gonna take our economy over here you
can't BAM oh my God he's taking my
account yeah all those miners off dead
now it's fine it's fine okay don't hit
the shield with that guy too yeah that's
it economies are in forever oh my god
we've only had to stop that the home
yeah no you know what i'm gonna go i'm
gonna taking risky strategy here good
idea i'm crazy yeah crazy I just want to
sell on a shocker that's all I want oh
no I'm gonna work that's not gonna work
personal comfortable your junk j
my mind is just one of mine in it down
on their family look at this and flow
you up i'm slowly gonna eat away at you
down here look you you just wait and see
right let's build a frost i'm here on
your own although it teresa i really
want that dollar i'm making this any
easier he doesn't make a lot of money
anybody keep everything burning cuz i'll
go anyhow to nearly had us he go keep
everything burning that sounds like Mary
kiss all right that house that burned
that on turn that on bring that up and
you got a fresh start wearing the back
god damn it hey around you looking
pretty bad isn't it fire it's pretty
dire all right take out uh I'm throw
that was good oh no I don't even have
like you're gonna need to get over there
and I'm really depressing more ice just
yeah just start shooting your stuff just
like shooting up Mary you know all about
that don't you oh my god I got so that's
right let's get you access to a mine
yeah no he keep keep your everything
firing my prize and comfy their mother
[ __ ] oh no but the field is far for it
is see see I'm planning it all along
really you gotta catch up on door enter
again but as close as you can this
episode mommy McCann name is because in
lasted for hours where's vacuum yeah cuz
the Flint tourists you through the Gary
know what's up yep there we go don't
have to [ __ ] the other night froster I
would another I'd put another bomb oh
and if you you know what if you can make
that hole go through on the bottom and
then get the bombs going down he's
coming after my stuff coming after my
good the bonds won't go up to just
concentrate on washing or bottom to the
raid build a flamethrower but you did
that was good that you versus in that
territory so she can't up right there
get a flamethrower and I'll blow him
open again sweet you might want to sell
your level 3 cannon get the money put
down more i could sell you actually wait
till you get enough
through and door that's closed you can
now we can all right there oh that's
perfect a couple more shots else walked
out with your key you cut down which you
stole my mind and I can't feel their
yeah bourse typical oil tea okay now you
think Don's right at the bottom I'm o on
that yeah get it go through oh it's big
well I cannon you like to steal Danny
you like it he's like Brazil I don't I
don't like Brazil why you keep saying
that Oh got that right here oh yeah tons
of money put as many bonds on the bottom
as you can okay and push them as far out
too and then just keep him firing here
thanks you and you can upgrade them
because he's really they're really
shooting the crap at him I did show that
you could do frost and fire to such my
God he's coming you can do that so our
main goal is we need to upgrade that ok
send that one on the wall don't worry
about the topic yeah all right I get
them all going on the bottom after me
[ __ ] yeah gold on yeah a few months
there yes you you you're gonna 60 bytes
for you back there Teresa is dangerous
well you know what I've got flames are
in the middle yeah that's perfect oh no
yeah and don't get the shield yep
perfect right there cut away right grade
make sure that the other one yelling
it's a light and then you can push out
for the money on the bottom two I can ya
come after me push out are we sleeping
with our bombs so grab a bomb which one
this ya see so I got no money to 73 yeah
it's nixa musically push that one out on
the mother you gotta be real with me
dude this is ty sir oh this is this
video games right here put a gold mine
in front of that feel like we have a
chance shoot I'm just yet yep good 20
games man money game oh I look forward
keep them firing Vic I'm actually
putting out there just to buy me some
time blocked by no now you can put it on
mine down there I'm gonna die and then
keep that fire ago I gotta go for it is
this the biggest comeback on video game
history John what's happening here is
ill yeah right now there were Merrick
works oh that look at that oh hi that
was brilliant i don't i didn't realize
that bottom strategy was gonna work out
so well that's great yo yo make it rain
make it rain make it drizzle just a
little bit next time next time on the
Benjamins baby Washington all right I
think we may have done a good job of
explaining Tigers oh you know what in
the world of CBS I games with a
wonderful a vending machines this is
four cans of diet coke right here my
dentist will be delighted and I think we
did a good job of kind of explaining how
fun that goddamn game could be the folks
at home want to get in on the action
when it's kind of brawl available for
how much it is available right now on
steam and it is forty percent off right
now wait so it's only sixty dollars the
only sixty dollars worth every penny and
which is that how much is it actually uh
899 899 I only got two payments left
yeah make that three just the banner
right now money just a beta right now so
you guys are still adding in
functionality yeah extra levels all that
sort of stuff up until finally sweet
which is when which is coming up at the
end of august sweet all right